the Duke and Duchess of Sussex are
moving yes Prince Harry and Megan Markel
guys this is a big deal
move into a new pad and joining me live
from London is our own correspondent
Rachel McGrady to break everything down
about this new up and up the new home
the new pad moving on up it's a question
mark reach okay thank you so much for
being here so everyone is talking about
this because Prince Harry and Megan
Markel moving away from Prince William
and Kate Middleton a question is what
does it mean but first let's talk about
where they're moving where had they
lived
I believe Kensington Palace and where
are they moving to now yes learned so
they originally lived in Nottingham
cottage on Kensington Palace Grounds
which was a rather small little cottage
for them and now they are moving over to
Windsor where the course they got
married last May and they're going to
the Frogmore cottage which we saw that
they had their wedding party after the
wedding itself that night on the
Frogmore estates and they also took
their wedding engagement photos there
back last fall so a very special place
for them and also a very practical
choice for them because it's a larger
space for their expanding family as
she's expecting a baby this spring well
I love how we call a cottage rage and
maybe if we can pull up those photos
again because cottage has a whole other
definition for the royal family yes I
remember this Frogmore house you and I
were actually driving around Windsor
when we were reporting for the royal
wedding and trying to find this because
we knew that the the after party was
gonna be here and we were trying to get
a glimpse and see if we could see some
of the attendees so this is where they
had the after party like you said a
special place but is that really the
reason bigger more space for their
expanding family I mean Kensington
Palace is pretty spacious oh there are
rumours about if something else is afoot
here what do we know about the
relationship between Harry and Megan
Will and Kate because what some people
are saying is that growing tension
between the two couples meant
and Megan wanted to move further away
from that yes so we have a royal source
who's spoken with et about it saying
that there is a bit of tension between
the Fab Four tragically but it's not
really quite as dramatic as it may seem
Harry and William of course have their
own separate duties to attend to in the
upcoming years William in line to the
throne and Harry with his focus on the
Invictus games HIV awareness mental
health so they're kind of leading
separate lives but we have been told
that Kate and Megan have kind of handled
things differently and sort of have
different focuses so they are a little
bit more separate and probably don't
want to be roommates isn't quite as much
over at Kensington Palace of course
Megan is known for kind of speaking out
about her feminist attitude towards
being a duchess and also women's
empowerment kate has very focused on
children's charities being a mother of
three herself but we have been told that
though there is a bit of tension that is
not the reason for the move the couple
needs this 10 bedroom cottage as you
mentioned for their nursery and also
there's space for a gym and a yoga
studio and all that kind of stuff so
obviously Megan who has called yoga her
escape in the past is going to want to
take advantage of that well right that's
the thing I mean she can't just go to a
yoga class like the rest of us and also
I know that we know her mother we'd
gotten reporting that her mom who lives
here in the u.s. of course has been
wanting to spend more time in London
especially as she becomes a grandmother
so more space for her mom now look I
feel like we're dancing around it a
little bit Rach I mean I don't want
there to be tension between Harry and
Megan and Will and Kate but I will also
say how could there not be when you
spend that much time together you go to
all these royal engagements together you
live on the same grounds like maybe this
you know we don't need on Everybody
Loves Raymond situation maybe they need
a little space yeah to school separately
they actually though they grew up
publicly in the spotlight together they
weren't actually together quite that
often growing up so they're close in
that the family is close and when your
Royall you kind of have to lean on each
other but they're not like the best of
pals or anything like that so I think it
makes sense for them now that Harry is
starting his own family to kind of
branch off and do their own thing and
have their own space and wins there's
only 45 minutes away from London driving
I'm sure we're going to see a lot more
of the Fab Four coming up okay well I
know I mean we know they're close
they're cute together I remember will
making that joke about how now that
Harry was getting married he wouldn't
come over to raid his refrigerator
anymore so you know what now he's
getting a refrigerator alisone in
Windsor Rach thank you so much
absolutely thanks Lauren
[Music]
[Applause]